Toddlers requested some yogurt this morning and we were running low,
so I just decided to make it myself.
They always have to have granola with their yogurt,
so I made that first by adding some oats,
cinnamon, maple syrup,
a smidge of peanut butter,
some coconut oil,
some coconut flakes.
I gave that really good mix
and also decided to add some peanuts in there as well.
I transferred that over to my baking sheet,
pressed it down,
and then pop that in the oven.
In the meantime,
I poured some milk into my pot and heated that up on the stove.
Once that barely reached a simmer,
I let that cool off,
pulled out my granola,
sprinkled it with some cherries,
cranberries, and some more coconut flakes.
When my milk was lukewarm,
I combined some of the leftover yogurt I have with the warm milk
before pouring it back into my milk,
covering that with a towel,
and letting it rest in a warm place for a few hours.
By this time, my granola had cold enough for me to break it up
and put it away in a glass jar.
Depending on the consistency you want your yogurt to be,
you can let it sit for about six hours or overnight
before popping it in the fridge for another few hours.
Once I pulled my pot out of the fridge,
I gave the yogurt a good mix and it was ready to serve.
Put some yogurt in The bowls topped it with the granola,
added some raspberries and obviously a drizzle of honey.
I popped any leftovers in the fridge
and they were so excited to have that.